[Musique]
comme la plupart des jeunes de son âge
l'ordinateur a toujours fait partie de
la vie de l'eau et qui à 21 ans ils
l'utilisent aujourd'hui principalement
pour étudier mais son utilisation s'est
transformé en cauchemar lorsqu'il avait
17 ans j'étais capable de me lever de
mon lit que j'ai été plus fonctionner la
seule chose dans ma vie que je me
sentais fonctionnel posté à jouer - mon
personnel j'étais heureux il y avait
succès mais en réalité la personne ne
rien contrôler c'est pas super facile
moi je pensais pas je vais te problème
ainsi leur dépendance
il ya le jouet a changé y rentrer dans
sa bulle il on le voyait le père d'une
autre on était potes
loïc avec l'aide de ses parents a suivi
un traitement pour s'en sortir
c'est ici au centre le grand chemin
qu'il a trouvé du soutien m'ont donné
mes outils à reconnaître à de quelque
chose qui vaut pop il le faudrait ptet
que la borde
il s'agit du seul endroit au québec qui
offre un service d'hébergement pour
aider les jeunes avec un problème de
cyberdépendance et les demandes se
multiplient depuis le début de la
pandémie isolement des jeunes et l'hyper
connectivité à internet inquiètes que
les intervenants s'est définitivement et
perd un devoir
c'est comme si lyon lyon rien d'autre à
faire ça donne une bonne chance à
jusqu'à faire ça toute la journée m non
pas des métiers dans sa chambre son
parrain nous on fait nos choses il enfin
fondeur chose il peut être intéressant
une petit niveau
parce que la détresse psychologique chez
les jeunes est bien réel et plus se
cacher derrière un écran
ici marie michel lauzon radio canada
montréal